brad two it's time to make a video
ah felix why do you always go in front
too why you are
brad too what you have a problem with
that this is mildly infuriating physics
oh it's mildly infuriating how
interested
cause that's the subreddit we're gonna
review so you don't
know just exactly how that feels this is
so much just
i know it's so bad i mean sorry
scythe one formerly known as brad two
yes the forgotten child of the pewdiepie
channel
i'm finally out the [ __ ] cage let's
go
[Laughter]
how do you feel now that you're side one
honestly i feel [ __ ] amazing okay
like finally brad's gonna have a
taste of being scythe too oh so he's
type 2
yes i was wondering why you call
yourself side one and i just saw it okay
that makes sense all right let's go into
the mildly infuriating
subreddit all right let's see this this
subreddit is already mildly infuriating
very meta i don't know if you can tell
like
they have that circle i legit thought it
was my discord
breaking wait that's the actual course
of the site yeah
looks like you're watching a youtube
video as well that's amazing
i'm generally annoyed and we haven't
even gotten started
why do i need account just to look at
printers sign up to see
more oh my god this legit this pisses me
off all the time because whenever i want
to edit for you and i look at
things to put on the video like pictures
they're always on pinterest websites
you go to pinterest for pictures of
course
i found your problem saying it's hard to
find some good
good quality stuff okay like yes
pictures on like low resolution i i get
it you're looking for the top notch
this is yeah i guess it's mildly
infuriating
yeah i i'd give it i'd give it a 2 out
of 10 2 out of 10.
okay it's just not too bad okay no this
is the top voted one it's got a hundred
thousand uploads people really hate
pinterest oh there you go i mainly hate
it when i search google for images and i
get pinterest results
see i knew it see that's what i'm saying
it's it's it's only hated because the
edit is okay
94.8k editors hate hey if you're an
editor and you're watching this video
smash like on this video if you agree
yeah yeah just a wee now north face
stole my photo and put it on their
shirts without
asking oh that is mildly infuriating
we get coffee strikes on youtube
meanwhile all these companies yeah
exactly yeah what the hell now i'm
furious
all right we get we give it an
elimination okay a little out of 10
everyone
i agree that's the perfect rating i hope
that
i can like work out my inferior like
actually i'm pissed by the end of this
that's the goal yeah that's the girl one
of a seemingly endless series of
unreasonable notes left by my boss it's
great here
nobody is entitled to charge up any
mobile phones or other electrical
devices on these premises
it's a theft of electricity and you may
find a deduction has been made from your
pay
phones should be switched off
hey i put up this note you did in the
office in the office
stop thieving from me brad one i mean
side one
hey damn bread one bread one eight i'm
hating on brad now hell yeah
i'm just confused this actually makes me
want to charge
like if i saw this note i would actually
just try and plug in a
charger as an actual savage my wife
never fully
screws the lid back onto anything jesus
christ
what is wrong with your wife
this is divorce worthy honestly does
monsieur do this
uh no she doesn't that's why the wedding
is still on
but she knows my set we're joking it's
okay
i like how they're they're offering
divorce counseling time to start leaving
the toilet seat up
it's the only thing you can do at that
point the only thing to save your
marriage
it's 50 50 okay equality all right
that's good
what would you rate this phoenix i have
a half of marriage i don't know what
have a marriage okay half a marriage
what about you
i'd rate this i'd rate this half of
marriage too okay
so we're full marriage then full
marriage
oh i've seen this one i would give him
10 stars but since i can't
for his 4 out of 5. sami is the
with the friendliest best copies that
would give him 10 stars if i can't
10 stars if i could too bad we'll give
him
four i love that
i can't tell if it's like genuine or not
like why
i used to get reviews like this at work
and they make me laugh when i was given
praise
in an overall comment but not given five
yeah five stars yeah
specific area yeah a lot of people do
that they're like oh this is so great
unlike google maps and stuff and you
just get like two out of five and then
the review is like oh this is amazing
this coffee is brilliant we give this a
4 out of 5 as well
i'll give this a 4 out of 5. absolutely
deserves nothing else
i would give it a 10 if i could then
this is what grinds my gears
white black asian gay
straight the person who originally made
this former and didn't capitalize their
eyes
oh i didn't realize this this changes
everything
i'm getting mildly infuriated what the
hell is it why would you do that
is that true i need to double check that
no i don't think i've even noticed i
don't think i'm nervous
oh my god oh no
what would you give this one felix um
[Laughter]
the price of 12 pieces of chalk at
target versus my college bookstore
okay so it's 99 and then 11
whoa what 12 bucks sorry this is like
if you if you go to the airport this is
what they charge you oh really
10 times the price they say no tax you
don't need to pay
tax you know buy oh but they started
surprises well i'm not buying my chalk
at the airport then
never never well this is why i just buy
online because i i don't know stores
amazon man
yeah best thing yep local businesses
this is the reason why
the uk economy is dying felix i remember
actually like
the only time i've been in a car
accident was when i drove
to get like a cable that i desperately
needed for a video oh my g
you went into a car accident yeah
because i left
so i went to this kid's store and
obviously they didn't have the cable
i knew they wouldn't have it but i
needed it like the same day and then i
left the store and i was so pissed and
then i
uh a car came out really fast no one got
hurt luckily but
this is why i say i order on amazon all
right
yeah but amazon doesn't deliver on the
same day how did you manage to get the
cable no i didn't and i
had my ball it's the worst day ever
that is so worried what do you mean
i'm a great driver okay i'll have you
know i'm a fantastic driver
first trillion dollar company there you
go apple
people everything's sold separately you
don't have any apple right
i know you don't know of course yeah
hell yeah this is what it looks like
when marcie edits the video
oh yeah she uses apple isn't it yeah
disgusting
yeah but the design looks really good
okay great congratulations
having more dongles or cables to the
side of adam
and she looks more intimidating damn i
think martial
definitely has damn no no no no no
she has it she's owning you
i'm buying an apple all right
this lady kneeling on breadwatch this
oh what
[Laughter]
what a dick move how how do you think
about doing that like you're in the
store
and you're kneading my knees are
slightly uncomfortable while i pick
bread oh great there's a pillow right
there
that's great listen that's just street
smart okay
i'm actually gonna do that next time i
pick bread
you have no legs that's what you need to
do
[Music]
oh yeah right i don't need to do it hey
do not fold and they folded it
good job we literally had this with brad
one it was the same thing like the
reddit we reviewed
well then it's like their college
application or something right oh
they're they're implement okay
that's annoying that's mildly
infuriating it was a social sciences
one so it doesn't that's the reason why
oh okay
if it was a science or math degree you'd
probably get it flat okay
hey i'm joking no no no that's good i
agree
i'm gonna piss off so many things no
even even themselves they're like yeah i
get it
if i wanted notifications i would have
allowed them stop asking every few days
enable notifications stay updated about
your posts
and comments well yeah red is annoying
because legit if you try and enter
their site which is no using a person
you just always get asked download the
app yeah
yeah i don't want to download the app
like i just want to view them
thank you no one has said this enough
okay
but do you know what's worse have you
have you ever had the duolingo app
where they always ask you basically it's
it's it's an app where you have to like
it's language right language yeah it's a
language and legit if you don't access
the app they will always spam you saying
you've got a lesson
you've got a lesson and it's so annoying
like it sounds like you're not doing
your lessons boy
what are you studying well i'm studying
i'm trying to learn trying to learn
swedish man
oh really wow so you can translate the
videos better i get it
exactly but yeah this is this is
definitely
mildly infuriating i give that a ten a
ten
a ten i get it at ten two so already
will stop pulling this
completely completely original post
got stolen and not only hit the front
page but was put in a buzzfeed article
that cited the reposter as a opie
ah this is why bushfied is not
a legitimate news sword oh my god i just
realized they make that
[ __ ] tale okay that's just nabbing
memes i think
yeah i think we can't really hate on
this one
what do you mean i don't know this is
the law of the internet this is the law
of the land all right
sharing is caring exactly
rate this a zero don't care god this
course is
annoying me so much like i think your
computer's like lagging oh really
my computer is fine all right doctor
appointment at 8 20. currently 10 still
no sign of even a nurse
yeah well this is just british
healthcare british healthcare
jesus christ well like every time i go
in
i wait 40 minutes and i always i sit
there every time going like why didn't i
just come 40 minutes late
because this happens every time i would
rather pay for my own health care than
this
what what why don't you feel okay you're
like multi-millionaire youtuber
i mean i do but i don't want to pay for
other people
[ __ ] neighbor keeps on stealing
stealing
my boyfriend's avos from history he
steals avocados
i mean that's just law of the land i'm
sorry
everyone
are you the one stealing my avocados
okay ios 12.
a row of numbers would have been nice
instead of all this
[ __ ] i funny though
so now you know all the people stealing
memes are apple users
oh we got facts
we got solid proof although on my damn
keyboard you know how i always like
punch it have a random dot in the
sentences why
well because the goddamn dot is right
next to the space and i try to hit the
space or to get a dot instead and i'm
like
god damn it why am i the only one with
this issue i don't understand like are
my thumbs too big restaurant reviews
like this
never been there never heard of it why
are reviews why do people do reviews
like this
i appreciate that i feel like that's the
kind of thing i would leave
why does this remind me of the time you
and rooney were talking about the
reviews
people found my account and they start
liking my reviews and stuff and
now they're going to find out who i am i
don't like it moving on
i'm not too furious though i like i wish
i was more pissed off
oh that is miley fury eating
every boy has been through this
experience or still suffers from this
wait what what do you mean this looks
like a boner i'm not gonna lie
yeah and then someone pokes and be like
oh you're gonna boo no i don't
the sweater curves
did you know zip and zippers are a
swedish invention so you're welcome the
world
oh damn sweet welcome to something good
for the world
like actually something ghost penises
that's what we accomplished
this lady watching a beach wedding they
put up yellow police tape all around the
beach for the wedding
yet somehow this random lady in the blue
system still felt the need to stand here
of all places to stand and watch the
whole thing
this is why you need guns oh oh
okay we gotta avoid this you want ads
let's avoid this okay
all right i wanna add you're right you
can just photoshop that away pretty
easily though
oh my god dude she's right there in the
corner
oh my god it just hit me this subreddit
is
is amazing oh that's great all right how
do you feel
side one do you feel mildly infuriated i
feel pissed off yeah i
agree well i feel great you're not a
human face okay
oh okay i see how it is now that you're
shy one should we make side two edit
this video
yeah let's make you mad this video i
need a day off okay all right i've done
two days worth of videos please okay
please
let me out the cage okay it sounds like
the job for type 2 now
i'm probably most likely gonna end this
yeah you're probably edited
smash like if you enjoyed check out
twitter
youtube link in description can i out
follow brad please
please oh okay away from out 5k
i mean it's time what just let's type
tuber
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new
minigame craniac drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game
and you say there's more of course there
is new knowledge perks
new quests and new pixellings
and legs guys
[Music]
like